اذا نتابع هذه الصور المتداوله للتفجير في
منشاه غاز في المحمديه في المغرب طبعا
المحمديه تقع في شمال شرق الدار البيضاء
مراسل العربيه كان قد اورد لنا بان سلطات
المغربيه تقول انه لم تسجل اي خسائر بشريه
في حريق محمديه وان فرق الانقاذ تحاول
السيطره على حريقه هذه المنشئه منشات
الغاز في المحمديه نستمع الى هذه الصور
المباشر
صور المتداوله
[تصفيق]
طيب معنى ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عادل
الزبير عادل ما هي التفاصيل حول هذا
الانفجار
وقع في اكبر في احد اكبر
شركه
تستورد هذا المطار من الخارج وتعبئه الى
غايه الان فرقوا الانقاذ منت او متواجده
في هذه الحي همم المتواجد في مدينه
المحمديه المحمديه موجوده بين العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط ومدينه الدار البيضاء
تسمى الاطفائي عقارب الساعه من اجل محاصره
السنه اللعب ومحاوله منع انتشار الحريق
الى خزانات اخرى لغاز البوتان لان مدينه
المحمديه
تتصل اليه البواخر التي يستوردها المغرب
من غاز البوتان من الخارج الى في الان لم
تعلن السلطات المغربيه عن تسجيل اي خسائر
بشريه في الارواح السلطات تحاول ابعاد
السكان من
في مكان الحريق المعلومات الاوليه تشير
الى بدايه التحكم في هذا الحريق الذي هزم
في جاره مدينه المحمديه
واخاب
ويها ولكن المعلومات القويه الاوليه من
السلطات المغربيه مطمئنه فرق الانقاذ
المتواجده ومن المرتقب في الساعات المقبله
ان تتم محافظه هذا الذهب اذا لم يتطور
الحريق خصوصا ان ال- ال- ال- الاحوال
الاحوال الجو والطق تساعده فرقه
الاطفائيين لمنتشرين في عين مكان وفرضت
السلطات سياج معدني وحواجز حديديه لمنع
السكان لمنعهم للاقتراب من مكان هذا
الحريق الذي يعتبر واحد من اكبر الحرائق
التي تعرفها عدل تخزين غاز البوتان في
المغرب
هل تحوطها البيوت بيوت السكان ام هي بعيده
نوعا ما هل السلطات اغلقت الشوارع المؤديه
اليها وبالتالي همم يعني في محاولتها كما
ذكرت بتطويق هذا الحريق
نعم السلطات المغربيه وضعت حواجز حديديه
لمنع السكان من الاقتراب من هذه المنشاه
المنشاه
قريب مناطق السكنيه ولكن هنالك مسافه امان
كافيه بحسب فرق الانقاذ الميدانيه
المتواجده في عيد المكان ما جعل
فرقا لان كل ما اقتربت هذه النيران من
السكان كما خطروا كبيرا ولكن الى غايه
الان حتى التلفزيون المغربي
نقل قبل خاء قليل اخبارا ااه تؤكد ان
الامور الى غايه الان تحت السيطره وهنالك
دعوات الى السكان لعدم الاقتراب من مكان
هذا الحريق الذي يعتبروا حريق كبير في
منشاه حساسه جدا لان الغاز سريع الاشتعال
غاز البوتان سريع الاشتعال وهو ما تكشف
هذه الصور المتدا
وله مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
هذا المشهد الذي يمكن وصفه بانه غير مسبوق
في تاريخ مدينه المحمديه التي تعرف تواجدا
لهذه المنشات المتخصصه في تخزين غاز
البوتان المستورد من خارج المغرب الى غايه
المعلومات المتوفره مطمنه الفرق الميداني
سائر بشريه وان الانفجار لم يتسبب في وقوع
اي ضحايا او شرحه الى غايه الان في انتظار
معلومات
اخرى المغربيه التي تنكتب الان خطه
ميدانيه لتسريع عمليه اخماد هذا الحريق
لحساسيه مكان الحريق لتواجد مجموعه من
نقاط تخزين وصهاري تخزين غاز البوتان لان
مدينه المحمديه هي مدينه تخزين غاز
البوتان في المغرب
لايضا المزيد من المعلومات
ونتمنى السلامه للمغرب شكرا جزيلا لك